president trump's push to reopen the
country comes as key polls find him
trailing presumptive democratic nominee
joe biden
chief washington correspondent major
garrett is with us now he's the host of
not one but two podcasts to take out and
debriefing
the briefing major good morning i want
to talk about those polls we just
mentioned
the president's self-review of the
administration's response to the virus
has been favorable
but voters may have a different opinion
what's the mood right now in the white
house
so the president is relentlessly upbeat
that's his nature but the poll numbers
that can be viewed publicly and
internally within the republican
national committee and the trump
campaign paid a very different picture
so let's take a one to ten scale one is
absolute political serenity
ten is a five alarm fire it's about an
eight inside the white house right now
because the president knows he's being
judged
as everyone in public life is being
judged on handling
the pandemic and charting the course for
the country to reopen and the mood
and the verdict is so far net negative
and the president's trying to find ways
to reverse that
he's having a much harder time than he
imagined and political advisers close to
the president know it
we have tens of thousands of americans
dead tens of millions of americans
out of work but the president is saying
this is going to go away
he wants to get back to normal and the
country will get back to normal
what's behind that strategy
that things can be the way they were
what does president trump want to return
to
he wants to return to a place where he
thought he was if not a shoe into
re-election
someone who had a very good path toward
reelection why because he had a strong
economy beneath him
and much of this political anxiety tony
is related entirely to anxiety about the
future of the us economy
because the president now knows even
though he said on monday oh the third
quarter is going to be spectacular no he
started to say
yesterday and the day before it's going
to be transitional he's been advised the
third quarter which is the quarter that
leads right into the november third
election
is going to be very dire indeed so the
president is trying to find some way
to pump up the psychic enthusiasm about
the economy even though the numbers in
the third quarter in the second quarter
are probably going to be very very bad
yeah the economy was going to be his
biggest selling point going into
re-election
uh he's also turned his political
rhetoric his fire
against china initially he praised the
country for its response to the virus
now
he is turning that into criticism what's
he hoping to gain there with american
voters
china was a big issue in 2016 probably
under appreciated by republicans who
challenged donald trump during the
primaries and by the hillary clinton
campaign and by democrats
in the 2016 general election it is
almost like immigration potent
simple and easy to define for the
president largely on his terms
it's going to be up to the country to
have an intelligent conversation about
china you can't say china did do nothing
wrong
china did several things wrong it did
not disclose what it knew
early enough to alert the world that's a
significant factual problem
to talk about a lab doesn't necessarily
mean it was man-made it could have been
studied as would be appropriate in china
to study avian viruses but that doesn't
mean it's man-made did it escape we
don't know yet but to have that
intelligent conversation
is going to be harder and harder in a
fueled political environment where the
president is going to try to make china
if not a scapegoat at least an excuse
for some of the things that he missed
early on
in dealing with this pandemic
all right and all this reminder that in
the midst of this pandemic we are
nonetheless less than six months away
from a presidential election major
garrett thank you very much